[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Satya we have a very
important topic that we are talking
about today we are going to be talking
about the me2 movement we're gonna be
talking about Cavanaugh and this is a
really important conversation and I
really want us to take a moment to take
a breath just drop into our body into
our heart be one with ourselves be one
with everything around us and let's
enter this conversation together
peacefully calmly in a nuance driven way
me too is arguably the biggest social
progress towards respect and towards
equality of opportunity of the 21st
century and that's massive so far that
we've gotten to the point that we have
and I'm very happy that we're
progressing towards respect and equality
of opportunity and I hope you are too
because that's the only way forward
we're transcending past superiority and
egos and we're moving towards a state of
love respect and equality of opportunity
so we haven't gotten to where we are
today without a lot of trauma on earth
ever since we really gained greater
cognitive capabilities we've been in
lots of war and suffering and pain to
get to where we are today and that
trauma needs to be integrated so we need
to openly have integrated that trauma
in a loving and peaceful way into our
essence so that way we can move forward
most effectively we've had tons of Wars
from even back in the earliest days when
we discovered territory and turf that
this land all of a sudden became my land
to this decaying flesh vehicle that's
going to die in 80 years all of a sudden
owns the land on earth
it's very egotistical to think about
things in that sense and then we started
killing other people for their land we
started killing other people that didn't
agree with us that don't believe in the
same deity or ideas that we do these are
divine beings that were murdering four
things four things we have a long way to
go to get to a point of transcending the
ego and becoming one and loving and
respecting each other on earth but we
got to get there together what else came
with territory we had stone weaponry we
had steel we had guns nukes over time so
ever since we gained these greater
cognitive capabilities we've been
murdering each other and we still see it
today with manifest destiny and with
imperialism this feeling of superiority
we're not at peace and we must truly
strive for peace and we got to stop
funneling money into war and
collectively funnel money into peace
love real education
and looking back at some of the ancient
civilizations in some ways they were
actually more connected to their
divinity than we are today in this
insane economic and political machinery
that we live in more time to focus on
their spiritual blueprint their souls
actualization than we do today when
we're running around trying to barely
piece together the finances needed in
order to pay for our basic living
expenses so what does this world look
like where we envision a stronger social
fabric infrastructure real education
community support systems where people
are actually actualized to their fullest
potential and we progress harmoniously
symbiotically with earth and I'm gonna
give you these examples of these traumas
that we've went through and I want to
integrate these into our lives I'm gonna
give specific ones because I gave the
broader ones with the sort of stone
tools steel tools nuclear weaponry and
we gave these examples earlier and that
was a very broad global sense now I want
to talk about specific ones in the
United States a lot of our viewership is
from the United States also a lot of
people from around the world watch and
understand a little bit about United
States manifest destiny and history of
how we got here and what we've done but
since we've gone here we've done things
like the Trail of Tears where we've
moved Native Americans that were on this
land worshiping living on this land and
loving harmoniously on this land before
us and we murdered ten thousand-plus of
them on the way of migrating them across
the United States into reservations we
need to integrate that trauma openly
lovingly caringly same thing with the
mexican-american war where we came and
we took over the land in the southern
and southwestern part of the
it's as part of manifest destiny and
fought for that again land that had been
lived on for long periods of time prior
to us we need to integrate that openly
slavery and segregation the North
Atlantic slave trade moved 12 and a half
million people from Africa to United
States Caribbean Europe and that is
insane that that many humans were moved
in a slave trade that is insane that's
so much that we have to integrate
peacefully into our lives again
harmoniously and and lovingly and
caringly integrate that and and make it
so that we can peacefully move forward
because that is some serious thing that
happened and the segregation that we had
in our schools and in public areas this
is insane and it used to be an ethical
norm back then to slap slaves and we
have to move forward and we have to
integrate this peacefully
women's suffrage the fact that only
around 1920 did women gain the right to
actually vote why did it take us that
long and how can we best move forward
integrating women as equal as of respect
towards women giving equality of
opportunity how can we do that Japanese
internment camps during World War two
the Middle East today were still
meddling we're still propagating war how
do we propagate peace how do we
propagate love all of this is trauma
that needs to be integrated about how we
got to where we are today with sea to
shining sea and don't get me wrong there
are still places in the world that are
doing this incorrectly 2018 and we still
see genitalia genital mutilation
because that's a pleasure it's a
pleasure system and if we can cut that
genital for a female then she can't
experience pleasure that is still okay
that there are still women that are
treated like property that there are
still women that have assigned a
marriage is happening to them in their
family systems for money and for
property there having assigned marriages
we had the one-child policy in China
where women were just thrown away young
babies that are girls are thrown away
and they keep the boys these are very
serious global traumas that still occur
today or that have been occurring in
just the last few years that we need to
peacefully integrate and move forward
with new strategy on respect and
equality letting people actualize their
divine blueprints it's not healthy when
we have megalomaniacs people that are
obsessed with power and greed that are
controlling and puppeteering the
economic and political machinery we must
fight back against that
one one last example of today's trauma
is something that is getting very close
to my heart as there are 1.1 million
people suffering from this today it is
the Rohingya ethnic and religious
persecution in Myanmar where the state
councillor on sound spooky
she's a Nobel Peace Prize laureate and
she isn't taking action on what's going
on with the religion people being
ethnically and religiously prosecuted
and moved from their place land in
Myanmar and they're beating refugees and
moving to Bangladesh 700,000 people in
just the last year and 300,000 in the
years before that so the President of
Bangladesh at the United Nations just
said there are 1.1 million Rohingya
refugees in Bangladesh now and the World
Bank in June 2018 put 500 million into
helping health education water
sanitation disaster risk management and
Social Protection the Koopaling refugee
camp is packed it's not healthy it's bad
energy we're not actualized in humans we
are creating more suffering and we need
to actualize these humans we need to
provide them with basic necessities for
them to become healthy happy and living
fruitfully and we can't have things that
are happening on our planet where we're
still religiously and ethnically
prosecuting we need to integrate this
trauma that's happening today still into
our lives we need to solve these
problems collectively we need to
transcend our egos and feelings of
superiority so the u.s. is still in some
ways at the forefront of recovering from
the trauma so now we're gonna show some
of the recovering Michu is actually
calling out the bad instances with
integrity and enthusiastic consent
culture is crucial moving forward when
you're with some
and you're playing with them and you're
hoping that you may escape to something
that is consensually agreed upon as
exciting sex intimacy the good stuff
that you really have to consensually
agree with enthusiasm not the and not
the no but the yes the hell yes for both
of you and I don't think that
Millennials and Gen Z and Beyond will
have this problem I think that we are
born into the digital footprint era and
we can't afford to transparently have
bad marks on our records so technology
has created trust in this sense I don't
think we're gonna have as much of this
issue moving forward because of these
digital blueprints so I heard the
definition of feminism as women are
humans should be treated as such
that's a rocking definition I think all
men and women can get behind this all
humans can we can get on board with not
objectifying when we see attractive men
or women we have to think of their soul
this has really helped me who they are
as an individual what their aspirations
are in life think of their heart not
their body this helps a lot
and if there are men and women who want
to be ejecta fide carefully check in and
get to know that people are ok with that
before doing so almost all people don't
like feeling unsafe please help make
sure people don't feel unsafe we must
also admit that there are deceitful
people who are attempting to rise up the
fame hierarchy this type of line for
fame has been happening since we gained
these cognitive abilities but it's being
scrutinized now more than ever because
they can achieve global recognition and
really can get paid for tearing down
people's careers using me - honestly is
crucial to the success of empowering men
as allies and actualizing the full
potential of women in this divine
feminine transition we're going through
and we talked about this divine feminine
transition on our last women in Alliance
event women want respect but more than
that they want
equality of opportunity all humans
deserve respect and equality of
opportunity it's tough to say all
because someone could literally be
coming at your throat with a knife and
they still deserve enough respect to get
them to medical treatment to aim to help
with their problem so feel what is
occurring with women stepping up into
leadership roles around the world I feel
really good about this today I connected
yesterday I connected with very powerful
female leadership in the sciences and
entrepreneurship in academia and I was
so honored they have worked their asses
off to make tremendous impact on the
world and I have so much respect for
when I got to pass time with them it was
a beautiful thing and we can have that
respect for women that have achieved
greatness in the world and it's so
important to have that deep honest love
care respect for that so think about
this if we are living in a world a
civilization that's evolved as a
simulation let's say and in this
simulation we've had a patriarchy we've
had a patriarchy so what is the good
that's come from the patriarchy and what
is the bad now imagine a simulation
where we've had a matriarchy what would
be the good that would come from the
matriarch and what would be the bad and
what I'm asking us to do is to smash
together the good from the patriarchy
the good from the matriarchy into one
civilization of balance and of love
respect equality of opportunity let's
get there together so remember we got to
integrate the trauma we got a propagate
peace and love and we have to have
respect and equality of opportunity for
all huge thank you for tuning in go
create go and build go and manifest your
destiny thank you so much much love
[Applause]